so that's where we're headed our search
engines will actually also know us very
well we will let them listen in our
conversations verbal written they'll
watch everything we're reading and
writing and saying and hearing and then
they'll be like a assistant it'll say
you know you were talking about how you
can get this supplement
phosphatidylcholine into the cells
yesterday in that conversation with Joe
you know there was research that came
out thirteen minutes ago that speaks to
that it'll be an assistant that helps
you through the day the day will answer
your questions before you ask them or
even before you realize you have a
question and you'll just get used to
this information popping up that you
want it and you'll be Amit you'll be
frustrated if you're thinking about
something and it doesn't immediately pop
up without you even having to ask for it
now I'm not actually predicting that
until 2029 that we will match human
intelligence but we can nonetheless do
things that humans can't do I mean
Watson if it read one page as I said
wouldn't be as strong as you or I but it
was able to read hundreds of millions of
pages and it's its ability to read each
page is going to increase so that's
where we're headed but then a comment on
that is it's not an alien invasion of
these intelligent machines to displace
us we will use them to make ourselves
smaller which is what we do today